transducers of
course everything is just some
combination of the same ingredients and
the shell is on the outside it's on
inside the cheese is in it's on top
whatever um I'm not claiming any novelty
here this is just another rearrangement
of the same old stuff as usual um but
you know sometimes the cheese on top you
know tastes better than when it's inside
all right so what are transducers the
basic idea is to go and look again at
map and filter and see if there's some
idea inside of them that could be made
more reusable than map and filter
because we see map and filter being
implemented over and over again in
different contexts right we have map and
filter on collections we have map and
filter on streams we have map and filter
on observables we were starting to WR
write map and filter and and so on on uh
channels
and there was just there's no sharing
here there's no ability to create
reusable things so we want to take the
essence out and see if we can reuse them
uh and the way that we're going to do
that is by recasting them as process
Transformations and I I'll talk a lot
more about that but that's essentially
the entire idea recasting the the core
logic of these what were sequence
processing functions as process
Transformations and then providing
context in which we could host those
transformation
so when I talk about processes what am I
saying it's not every kind of process
there are all kinds of processes that
cannot be modeled this way but there are
a ton of processes that can right and
and the critical words here are that if
you can model your process as a
succession of
steps right and if you can talk about a
step or think about a step as ingesting
an input as taking in or absorbing some
input a single input so something going
on there's an input we're going to
absorb that input into the something
going on and proceed uh that's the kind
of process that we can U use transducers
on uh and and when you think about it
that way building a collection is just
one instance of a process with that
shape right building a collection is you
have the collection so far you have the
new input and you incorporate the new
input into the collection and you keep
going right but that's a specialization
of the idea the general idea um is the
idea of a seated left reduce of you know
taking something that youve building up
and a new thing and continually building
up but we want to get away from the idea
that the reduction is about creating a
particular thing and focus more on it
being a process some processes build
particular things other processes are
infinite they just run
indefinitely so we made up words
actually didn't make up a word again
this is actually a word uh but why why
this word well we think think it's
related to reduce and reduce is already
a programming word and it's also already
a regular word and the regular word
means to lead back right to to bring
something back uh and and we've sort of
the the word has come to mean over time
to bring something down or to make
something smaller it doesn't doesn't
necessarily mean that it just means to
lead it back to some you know Mothership
and in this case we're going to say this
process that we're trying to accomplish
uh the word ingest means to carry
something into so it's the same kind of
idea but that's about one bite right
reduction is about a series of things
and ingestion ingest itself means you
know one thing and transduce means to
lead across and the idea basically is as
we're taking inputs into this reduction
we're going to lead them through a
series of Transformations we're going to
carry them across a set of functions so
we're going to be talking about
manipulating input during a
reduction so this is not a programming
thing thing this is a thing that we do
all the time in the real world we don't
call them transducers we call them
instructions right and so we will talk
about this scenario through the course
of this talk which is uh put the baggage
on the
plane right that's the overall thing
that we're doing but I have this
transformation I want you to do to the
baggage right I want you to while you're
doing it while you're putting the
baggage on the plane break apart the
pallets so we're going to have pallets
you know big you know
wooden things with a pile of luggage on
it that's sort of shrink wrapped we want
to we want to break them apart so now we
have individual pieces of luggage we
want to smell each bag and see if it
smells like food if it smells like food
we don't want to put it on the plane and
then we want to take the bags and see if
they're heavy and we want to label
them right that's what you have to do so
we're talking to the luggage handlers we
say that's what you're going to do and
they all say great I can do
that one of the really important things
about the way that was just said and the
way you talk to luggage handlers and
your kids and anybody else who need to
give instructions to is that the
conveyance and the sources and the syns
of that process are irrelevant right do
the luggage handlers get the bags on a
conveyor belt or on a
trolley we didn't say we don't care in
fact we really don't want to care we
don't want to say to the luggage guys
today
there's going to be luggage on a trolley
do this to it and then put it on another
trolley and then tomorrow when we switch
to conveyor bels have them say we didn't
know what to
do I you know it came on a conveyor belt
and
like you you didn't you know I have a
rules for
trolleys uh so the rules don't care the
instructions don't care right this is
the real world right then we have
programming what do we do in programming
we we have collection function
composition we we're so cool you know we
have lists we have functions from list
to list right so we can compose our
functions we're going to say well
labeling the heavy bags is like mapping
right every bag comes through and it
gets a label or it doesn't but you know
for every bag that comes through there's
a bag that comes out and maybe it has a
labor or it doesn't and and taking out
the non-il nonf food bags is or keeping
the non food bags is a filter right it's
analogous to filter right is it food we
don't want it if it's not food we're
going to keep it so we may or may not
have an input depending on this
predicate and unbundling the pallets is
like mapat you know there's some
function that given a pallet gives you a
whole bunch of individual pieces of
luggage so we already know how to do
this we're done we're finished
programming can model the real
world uh except there's a big difference
between this and what I just described
happens in the real world right because
map is a function from whatever
collection to collection or sequence to
sequence or you know pick your
programming language but it's basically
a function of aggregate to Aggregate and
so is filter and so is mapat right and
the rules that we have only work on
those things they're not independent of
those things and when we have something
new like a Channel or a stream or an
observable none of the rules we have
apply to that and in addition we have
all this in between stuff it's as if we
said to the luggage guys take everything
off the truck trolley trolley right and
unbundle the pallet and put it on
another trolley right and then take it
off that trolley and then see if it
smells like food and if it doesn't put
it on another trolley and then take it
off that trolley and if it's heavy put a
label on it and put it on another trol
this is what we're doing in programming
it's what we do all the time right and
we wait for a sufficiently smart
supervisor to come and like say what are
you guys
doing
right uh
so we don't we don't we don't want to do
this anymore right we don't have any
reuse right every time we do this we end
up writing a new thing you write a new
kind of stream you have a new set of
these functions right you you invent RX
boom you know was a 100 functions uh we
were starting to do this enclosure right
we had channels and we're starting to
write map and filter again so it's time
to say time out can we can we do this
because there are two things that happen
one is all the things we're doing are
specific and the other is there's a
potential inefficiency here right yeah
maybe there are sufficiently smart
compilers and maybe for some context
they can make the intermediate stuff go
away maybe they
can't uh the problem is our initial
statement really doesn't like what we
normally do it's not General it's
specific we're relying on something else
to fix it right we also have this
problem right when we're going to go
from you know one kind of conveyance to
another and now all of a sudden well
well you know map is from X to X and
whatever you know how do we fix this um
and I know what everybody's thinking of
course
uh
yeah so I mean that may fix some of this
but in general uh it doesn't solve the
problem and the problem is is mostly
about the fact that we're talking about
the entire
job right those instruction
they were about the step they weren't
about the entire job the entire job was
around it while you're doing this thing
here's what you're going to do to the
inputs here's how you're going to
transform them while you're doing the
bigger thing which could change right we
could change from converyor belts to
trolleys and stuff like that so we want
to just take a different approach right
if we have something that's about the
steps we can build things that are about
the whole jobs but not vice
versa okay so just just going to be some
usages here and then I'll explain the
details in a little bit because usually
I do it the opposite way and people are
like oh my brain hurt for so long and
then like 40 minutes in you show me the
thing that made it all valuable so
here's the value proposition right we
make transducers like this we say I want
to make a transducer I want to make a
set of instructions I'm going to call it
process bags I'm going to compose uh the
idea of map catting using unbundle
pallet as the function right so I want
to unbundle the pallets then I want to
filter out the non food or or keep the
non food filter out the food and I want
to map labeling the heavy
bags uh and in in this case and we're
going to compose those functions with
comp which is closure's ordinary
function composition thing right so map
catting filtering and mapping return
transducers uh and process bags which is
the composition of those things is
itself a transducer so we're going to
call map catting call filtering call
mapping get three transducers compose
them and make another
transducer right each transducer takes a
process step right or its reducing
function and transforms it changes it a
little bit says before you do that step
uh do
this I'll explain why that seems
backwards in a little
bit having made those instructions we
can go into completely different
contexts and reuse them right amongst
the several contexts that were
supporting enclosure in the first
version is supporting transducers in
into and into is closure function that
takes a collection and another
collection and pours one into the other
instead of having you know more
object-oriented you know collections
that know how to absorb other
collections with build from we just had
the Standalone thing called into but
it's the same idea your source and
destination could be different um so we
want to pour the pallets into the
airplane but we're we're going to take
them through this process bags
transformation first so this is
collection building into it was already
a function enclosure we just added an
additional aity that takes transducers
right then we have sequence sequence
takes some source of stuff and makes a
lazy sequence out of it sequence now
additionally takes a
transducer and will perform that
transformation and all the stuff as it
lazily produces results so we can get
laziness out of this uh there's a
function called transduce which is just
like reduce except it also takes a
transducer so that takes uh a
transducer an operation an initial value
and a source so the the transducer is a
modification of process bags I'll talk
about in a second the operation is sum
the initial value is zero and the source
of the pallets so what is this
composition do what is this going to
do it's G to sum the weight of the bags
it's the weight of all the bags right so
it's cool look we can take the process
that we already had and modify it a
little bit we can add weighing the bags
at the end of that set of instructions
and that gives us a number and we can
use that number uh with plus to build a
sum so that's transduced the other thing
we can do is go to a completely
different context now so we have some
channels we're going to be sending
pallets of luggage across channels of
course that they won't really fit but uh
the idea is there this is a very
different context channels run
indefinitely right you can feed them
stuff all the time and get stuff out of
the other end on a continuous basis but
the the critical thing here is that this
is not these things are not
parameterized right they're not um I'm a
thing that you can tell me later you're
going to tell me if it's trolley or
conveyor belts this is the exact same
process bags I defin here this concrete
thing being reused in completely
different context
so this is concrete reuse not
parameterization so we can use uh
transducers on channels the channel
Constructor now optionally takes a
transducer and it will transduce
everything that flows through right it
has its own internal processing step and
it's going to modify its inputs
accordingly with the transducer it's
given and it's an open system I can
imagine but I did not get time to
implement that you could plug this into
RX Java trivially and take half of the
RX Java functions and throw them away
because you can just build a transducer
and plug it into one observable function
that takes an observable and a
transducer and returns an observable and
that's the
idea uh so we call all of these things
into and sequence and transduce and Chan
uh transducible processes they they they
satisfy that definition of process we
gave before um and they accept a
transducer so transducers sort of have
two parts Parts you make functions that
create transducers and in in context
where they make sense you start
accepting transducers and then you have
these two orthogonal Legos you can put
together right inside each process
they're going to take that transducer
and which and their internal processing
function so what's the internal
processing function of into the thing
that adds one thing to a collection
enclosure it's called con for conjoin
right similarly inside uh lazy sequences
there some thunk mechanism that uh
produces a result on demand and then
waits to produce the next thing so that
has a step inside of it that can be
transformed this way channels also take
inputs somewhere inside channels is a
little step function that adds an input
to a buffer that step function has
exactly the same shape as con and as
laziness so it can transform its
fundamental internal operation but the
operation remains completely
encapsulated right the transducible
context takes the trans ucer modifies
its own step function and proceeds with
that so uh as I said before there's
nothing new um two papers I find useful
for helping you think about these things
are this lectures and Constructor
functional programming which is a lot
closer to the source of when you know
people started thinking about um folds
and their relationship to uh to lists
and the second Graham Hunton paper is
sort of a summary paper which sort of
just summarizes the the current thinking
at the time it was written so they're
both really good uh but now I'm going to
take you through like how do we get to
this point how do we how do we think
about these things so one of the
fundamental things that the bird paper
and the work that preceded it talk about
is the relationship between these uh
list processing operations and fold in
fact there's a lot of interesting uh
mathematics that shows that they're the
same thing right that you can go
backwards and forwards between the the a
concrete list and and the operations
that constructed it they're sort of
isomorphic to each other right so many
of the list functions that we have can
be redefined in terms of fold right um
there's already been the definition of
map in several U talks here I think uh
but the the traditional definition of
map says you know if it's empty return
empty sequence if you're getting a new
input cons that input onto the result of
mapping to the rest of the input right
it's recursive and calls itself um but
you know map does that filter does that
map cat does they all they all sort of
have these structures but filter is a
little bit different right it has a
predicate inside it has a conditional
branch and then it then it recurses in
two parts of the branch with different
arguments so what this work this earlier
work did was say you can think about all
these things as folds if you do you get
a lot of regularity and things that you
can prove about folds which are now All
Uniform will apply to all these
functions that otherwise look a little
bit different from each other so there's
a lot of value to this fold encapsulates
the recursion right and it's easy to
reason about so if we look at a you know
a redefinition of map it's not often
defined this way but if we if we look at
a redefinition of map in terms of fold
then we say we're going to fold this
function that conses the first thing
onto the rest uh and we start with an
empty list so this is fold fold right
and we do that over a collection we can
similarly Define filter this way and
what's really interesting about these
things is that the fold R the empty list
and the call that's all boilerplate
right it's exactly the same map and
filter are precisely the same in those
things all that's different is what's
inside the inner function definition and
even there there's something the
same U so it ends up that you can
similarly redefine these functions or
Define these functions in terms of uh
fold L and fold Dell is just left reduce
U and so here's some here's some what if
definitions of map and filter and we
added map cat uh that are left folds
that use uh that use left reduce and and
so the the trade-off between left reduce
and right reduce is Right reduce sort of
put put you on the laziness path and
left reduce puts you on the loop path it
ends up that the loop path is is better
and faster and more general for the
kinds of things we want to apply this to
especially if we can get laziness later
which I just said uh we kind of could uh
so we like that so this means we can
turn these things into loops right cuz
reduce becomes a loop uh but the same
thing we have the boiler plate we have
reduce right these definitions use
vectors which inclosure are uh they're
like arrays but their fundamental coning
operation adds at the end so this has
the same shape I want to talk about for
the rest of the talk we have something
that we're building up a new input and
we produce a new thing and sort of the
stuff's coming from the right and
getting added to the right hand side so
it just makes more sense here so the
these are eager and they return vectors
but it's the same idea we're reducing we
have a function that takes you know the
vector so far and a new value we're
conjoining the new value having applied
F to it right that's the idea of mapping
right there's an idea behind mapping
that luggage handlers understand right
put the label on everything that comes
through that's very general right that's
mapping they get that we get that we're
all human beings we understand the same
thing as programmers we've mucked this
up because look at What's happen here
map says there's this fundamental thing
that you do to everything as it comes
through filter says there's this
fundamental tiny thing that you do to
everything as it comes through and mapat
says it's this fundamental tiny thing
that you do to everything as it comes
through what's the
problem
con con is basically like saying to the
trolley or to the conveyor belt right
it's something about the outer job
that's leaked or it's inside inside the
middle of the idea inside the middle of
the idea of mapping is this Con it does
not belong inside the middle of the idea
a filter is this Con it shouldn't be
there same thing with
mapat this is specific stuff in the
middle of a general idea the general
idea is just take stuff out we don't
want to know about con maybe we want to
do something different okay so again we
have a lot of boiler plate we have these
essences and the other critical thing is
the Essences can be expressed as
reducing functions each of these little
inner functions is exactly the same
shape as KH takes a result so far and a
new input Returns the next
result so to turn those inner functions
into into transducers we're just going
to
parameterize that con right we're going
to we're going to parameterize the
oldfashioned way with the function
argument you know anything higher order
blah blah blah you know we're going to
take an argument which is the
step so right in the middle body of this
mapping you see my curs no you can't see
my curs oh you can see it there right in
the middle but this is the same as it
was on the last slide this is where it
said Con now we say step we put that
inside a function that takes the step so
this is a function uh mapping takes the
the thing that you're going to map you
know label the baggage right and it
returns some something that is a
function that expects a step what are we
doing putting stuff on conveyor belts
what are we doing we're putting stuff on
trolleys okay and it says before I do
that I'm going to call F on the luggage
I'm going to put a label on the luggage
but I don't know about luggage anymore
the step you're going to tell me later
what are we doing today conveyor belts
or trolleys conveyor belts cool I got
the rules I understand how to do mapping
and filtering and and and map catting so
same thing filter and what's beautiful
about this is what's the essence of
filtering apply a predicate then maybe
you do the step or maybe you don't
there's no stuff here right it's a
choice about activity it's a choice
about action same thing with concatenate
cat what does it do basically says do
the step more than once I'm giving you
an input that's really a set of things
do it to each
thing and map catting is just composing
map and Cat which it should
be okay
so we can take these uh transducer
returning functions so mapping returns a
transducer filtering returns a
transducer cat is a
transducer and map catting returns a
transducer and we can then plug them
into the code we saw before like how
could we Define map now that we've made
mapping into this abstract thing that
doesn't really know about lists or
vectors anymore and what we do is we
just call mapping that gives us a
transducer it says if you give me a step
function I'll modify it to do F first on
the input and we say okay here's the
step
function now I rebuilt the functions I
had before except con is not inside
mapping and filtering and map catting
anymore it's an
argument
woohoo we now have the essence of these
things alak
cart and that's the point right
transducers are fully decoupled from
they don't know what they're doing right
they don't know what process they're
modifying the step function is
completely encapsulated right they have
some Freedom right they can call the
step function not at all once exactly
per input or more than once per input
but they don't really know what it does
so that's what they're limited to doing
using it or not using it that's pretty
much it except they do have access to
the input right so when we said map cat
unbundle pallet the function worth
supplying there is something that knows
about pallets it doesn't know about
conveyor belts it doesn't know what the
overall job is but it knows about
pallets and it's going to know how to
turn a pallet into a set of pieces of
luggage uh there's a critical thing
about how they use that step function
that they've been passing it goes back
to that successor notion I mentioned
before they must pass the previous
result from calling the step function as
the next first argument to the next call
to the step function that is the rule
for step functions and their use and no
others they can transform the input
argument the second ARG
so let's talk a little bit about the
backwards part because this is a
frequent question I get um what did you
do does transducers change comp is the
first thing like they M they ruin comp
or something like that and so what we
have to do is look at what transducers
do right a transducer function takes a
function wraps it and returns a new Step
function that is still happening right
to left this is ordinary comp and it
works right to left so mapping gets run
first right we're going to have some
operation you know put stuff on a
trolley or con right mapping will be the
first thing that happens it's going to
make a little modified step that labels
the heavy bags before it calls put it on
the
airplane then filtering gets called it
does go right to left it says give me
that step I'll make you a new Step that
first sees if it's food if it's food I'm
going to throw it away if it's not food
I'm going to use it then map catting
runs or the result of map catting runs
and that says give me a step and I will
um take its input presume it's a pallet
unbundle it and Supply each of those
arguments to the nested thing so the
composition of the Transformers runs
right to left but it builds a
transformation step that runs in the
order that they appear left to right in
the comp in other words comp's working
ordinarily it's building steps right to
left the resulting step runs the
Transformations left to right so when we
actually run this we'll unbundle the
pallets first call The Next Step which
is to get rid of the food call The Next
Step which is to label the heavy bags so
that's why it looks
backwards okay so the other nice thing
about transducers is that there's no
intermediate stuff they're just a stack
of function calls they're short
potentially they could be
inlined uh there's no laziness overhead
there's no laziness require there's no
laziness utilized right there's no
interim collections we're not going to
tell have you make everything into a
list so you can say no an empty list is
nothing no nothing is nothing empty list
is an empty list and one thing is one
thing a list of one thing is a list of
one thing and these are not the same uh
so there you know you use the step
function or you don't and there's no
extra boxes required of boxing for
communicating about you know the
mechanism so the other thing that was
sort of interesting was
uh you know I started talking about
transducers and a lot of people in hll
were trying to you know figure out what
the actual types were because I had uh
Shand in my blog post and I'm not going
to get into that right now uh except to
say that um I think it's a very
interesting type problem and I'm very
excited to see uh how people do with it
in their various languages I've seen
results that were sort of it works
pretty well to man types are you know
these types are killing me depending on
whether the users type system could deal
with it but let's just try to capture
what we know so far graphically and uh
somebody who reviewed these slides for
me said these should have been
subscripts but like computers are so
hard to use I couldn't switch them in
time so so they're superscripts but the
idea is that if you're trying to produce
the next process n you must Supply the
result from Step n minus one as the
input right if you try to model this in
your type system saying R to R that's
wrong
right because I can call the step
function five times and then on the
sixth time take the return value from
the first time and pass it as the first
thing that's wrong so you got to make
your type system make that wrong so
figure that out also if you make the
black box and the black box the same
thing that's also arbitrarily
restrictive right you could have a state
machine that every time it was given X
returned y every time it was given y
returned Z every time it was given Z
returned X that's a perfectly valid step
function it has three separate input
types and three separate output types
that only happen at particular times
there's nothing wrong with that state
machine it is a perfectly fine reducing
function it may you know be tough to
model in a type system and don't say X
or Y or Z because it doesn't take X or Y
or Z and return X or Y or Z when it's
given X it only returns y it never
returns Z so um seems like a good
project for the bar later on but the the
thing that we're capturing here is that
the new Step function might take a
different kind of input it might take a
b instead of an a that our first step
does that it takes a pallet and returns
a piece a set of pieces of luggage but
each step returns uh a piece of luggage
okay so um there are other interesting
things that happen in processes right
ordinary reduction processes everything
but we want this to be usable in cases
that run arbitrarily long we're not just
talking about turning one kind of
collection into another kind of
collection right a transducer that's
running on a channel has got an
arbitrary amount of stuff coming through
a transducer on an event stream has an
but sometimes you want to you know
either the reducing process or somebody
says whoa I have had enough I don't want
to see any more input we're done I want
to say we're done now even though you
may have more input so we're going to
call that early termination and it may
be desired by the process itself like
the thing at the bottom or it may be a
function of one of the steps one of the
steps may say you know what that's all I
was supposed to do and so I don't want
to see any more
input and the example here will be you
know we're going to modify our
instructions and say if the bag is
ticking you're finished go
home we're we're done loading the plane
so we're going to add that taking while
taking while
non-ticking right and taking while
non-ticking needs to stop the whole job
in the middle it doesn't matter if
there's more stuff on the trolley when
it's ticking we're
finished okay so how do we do that uh in
ends up enclosure we already have
support for this idea in reduced uh
there's a there's a Constructor of a
special you know uh wrapper object
called reduced which says this
represents the end of the of the it just
says I don't want to see any more input
here's the here's what I've come up with
so far and don't give me any more input
and there's a there's a predicate called
reduce question mark that allows you to
ask if something is in this wrapper
right and there's a way to unwrap the
thing and look at look at what's in it
so you can say you know is a reduced
thing reduced that will always return
true and you can D or reduce thing and
get the thing that's inside it um this
is not the same thing as maybe right
because maybe also wraps the other
things that are not reduced right or
either or all those other boxy kind of
things so we don't do that we just have
a we only wrap when we're doing this
special
termination so uh like reduced
transducers also must support reduced
that means that the step functions are
allowed to return a reduced value and
that if a transducing process or a
transducer gets a uh reduced value it
must never call the step function with
input again that's the rule again
implement the rule in your type system
have at it but that's the rule okay so
now we can look at the insides of taking
while it takes a predicate it takes a
step that it's going to modify it runs
runs the predicate on the input if it if
it's uh if it's okay it runs the step if
it's not okay it takes what has been
built up so far and says we're finished
reduced result that's how we bail out
but notice the ordinary result is not in
a
rapper and so the reducing processes
must also play this game right the
transducer has to play follow the rule
from before and a reducing process
similarly has to support reduced if it
ever sees a reduced thing it must never
Supply input again right the D reference
value is the final accumulated
value uh but the final accumulated value
is still subject to completion which I'm
going to talk about in a second right so
so there's a rule for the transducers as
well they have to they have to follow
this rule so now we get new pictorial
types in this in the graphical type
language that is omn
Graal
uh so we can have we can have uh you
know a a process right that's takes some
black box at at at the prior step and an
input and Returns the black box at the
next step or maybe right it returns A
reduced version of that so one of those
two things can happen or vertical bars
or right and it returns another step
function that's similarly can take a
different kind of input a blackbox
returns a blackbox or reduced
blackbox same rules about successorship
apply all right
so some interesting uh sequence
functions require State and in the
purely functional implementations they
get to use the stack or laziness to put
that state right they get somewhere in
the in the execution Machinery a place
to put stuff now we're saying I don't
want to be in the business of specifying
we're lazy or not lazy or um
uh or
recursive right I'm not going to give
you space inside the execution strategy
because I'm trying to keep the execution
strategy from you and that means that
state has to be explicit when you have
transducers each transducer that needs
state must create it so examples of
sequence functions that need state are
take partition all partition bu and
things like that right they have they're
counting or they're accumulating some
stuff to spit it out later um where's
that going to go and it has to go inside
the transducer object they have to make
State and there's some rules about that
if you need State as a transducer author
you have to create it every time
uniquely and again every time you're
asked to transform a step function so a
new you're going to create state every
time you transform a step function um
that means that if you build up a a
transducer stack some of which are uh
stateful transducers and you apply it
right not when you build it no State
exists then now after you called comp
there's no State when you've applied it
you now have a new process step but as
we should be thinking about all
transducer process steps including the
ones at the bottom right that may be
stateful you don't know that the very
bottom process isn't you know launch
stuff into space right so you should
always treat an applied transducer stack
as if it returned a stateful process
which means you shouldn't alas it what
ends up happening in practice is all of
the transducible processes they do the
applying it's not in the users's hands
to do it you pass around a transducer
and and and input to the job to the job
the job applies the transducer to its
process gets a fresh set of State when
it does that and there's no harm but you
do have to do this by
convention so here's an example of a
stateful transducer dropping while a
predicate is true right so we start with
our flag that says it's true right as
long as it's still true we're going to
drop when we see that it's not true
we're going to reset it and and continue
with applying the step and then from
then on forward we're going to apply the
step so
that is not the prettiest
thing I talked before about completion
so we have the idea of early termination
the other idea that transducer support
is completion right which is that at the
at the end of input which may not happen
right there'll be plenty of jobs that
don't complete they don't have ends
they're not consuming a finite thing
like a collection they're processing
everything that comes through a Channel
or everything that comes through an
Event Source there's no end but for
things that have end there's a notion of
completion which is to say if either the
innermost process step wants to do
something finally when everything's
finished they can or if any of the
transducers have some flushing they need
to do they can do it right so the
process may want to do a final
transformation on the output any
stateful transducer in particular a
transducer like um partition right it's
it's it's aggregating to to to return
Aggregates you say partition you know
five and it collects five things and
spits it out if you say we're done it's
got three things it wants to spit out
the three things but you need to be able
to tell it we we exhausted
input in order to do that the way that's
implemented in the closure
implementation of transducers is that
all the step functions must have a
second operation right so there the
operation that takes a new input and and
the accumulated value so far and returns
a new accumulated value uh or whatever I
mean it's up to the process what the
meaning of the black boxes uh but there
must be another operation which takes
just the uh accumulated value and no
input so Anar one operation so that's
required so we'll talk about what that
does or how that gets used right if the
process itself if the overall job is has
finished they exhausted input or it has
a not a notion of being finished this is
not bailing out this is like there's
nothing more to do there's no more input
ordinarily um it must call the
completion operation exactly once on the
accumulated value so there's no more
inputs I'm going to call you once with
no input do whatever you want each
transducer must do the same thing it has
to have one of these completion
operations and it must call its nested
completion
operation it may however before it does
that flush so if you have something like
partition U that's accumulated some
stuff along the way um it can call the
ordinary step function and then call
compl complete on the result and that's
how we accomplish
flushing uh there's just one caveat here
which is that if you're a stateful thing
like partition and you've ever seen
reduced come
up well the earlier rule says you can
never call the input function so you
just drop whatever you have hanging
around because somebody bailed out on
this process there's no there's going to
be no ordinary
completion so we can look at our types
again in uh omnigraffle 2000 the latest
uh programming Innovation and and think
about a TR as as a a a reducing function
as a pair of operations right they'll be
different in each programming language
it's not it's not really important right
enclosure it ends up a single function
can capture both of these aties but
whatever you need to do to take two
operations right the first one there
that takes no input is the completion
operation and the second is the step
operation that we've been seeing so far
it takes a pair of those things and
returns a pair of those things that's
that's
it and again we don't want to concretely
parameterize the result type there
either right you got to use rank two Pi
morphism or something because if you
concretely par parameterize that you'll
have something that only knows about
transducing you know into airplanes as
opposed to the general
instructions okay there's a third kind
of operation that's associated with sort
of processing in general um which is
init um we've had talks before that
mentioned monoids and things like that
it's basic the basic idea is just um
sometimes it's nice for a transformation
operation to carry around an
initialization
capability um it need not be the
identity value or anything like that it
does not matter uh what does matter is
that a reducing function is allowed to
May support aity zero in other words
given nothing at all here's an initial
accumulator value from nothing obviously
a transducer can't do that because it's
a black box the one thing it definitely
does not know how to do is make a black
box out of nothing right can't do it so
all it can ever do is called down to the
nested function um so transducers must
support aity Zer in knit and they just
Define it in terms of a call to the
nested step they can't really do it but
they can carry it forward so that the
resulting transducer also has an init if
the bottom transducer has an init um
I've talked about the a overload loing
and so here's here's an example oh I'm
over time already I'm sorry uh so here's
an example right plus from list this is
old this is older than transducers right
list programmers have been doing this
for a while sorry currying fans this is
what we do uh plus with nothing Returns
the identity value for plus zero
multiplication with nothing returns one
right I uh it implements plus of of an
accumulated result as identity and the
binary operation that does the work so
here's the types
again we now have an optional in it from
nothing and we're taking a set of three
operations and returning a new set of
three operations enclosure we just Ed uh
AR to do this a transducer enclosure
then is just something that takes a
reducing function and returns one where
a reducing function has these three
arities um we haven't actually called
the reducing functions mapping and
filtering and in this and in that I
think that's an englishis that's not
going to carry over very well uh and we
have available to us already overloading
because we don't have currying so map of
f with no collection argument Returns
the transducer and we've modified so far
all of these sequence functions to do
that so this is a final example of
filter returning a
transducer right it just takes a it
takes a predicate and returns this a
step modifying function which takes a
reducing function which presumably has
these three arities and defines a
function with three arities init which
just flows it through because it doesn't
know what it could possibly do complete
filter doesn't have anything special to
do so it just flows that through and
then the resultant input one which is
the one we've seen before then we can
see we can Define The Collection
implementing one by just calling
sequence uh with this transducer and
that's true of all of these functions
you can Define The Collection version
exactly like this which shows that
transducer is more primitive than the
other so this is what we're trying to
accomplish you define a set of
transducers once you define all your new
cool stuff right channels today
observables tomorrow whatever the next
day you just make it except
transducers and and every specific
implementation of these things you get
for free and every recipe that somebody
creates that's a a composition of those
transducing operations works with your
thing right
away um that's what we want right we're
going to take peus and just say it's
even better we want 100 uh functions
with no data
structure
so transducers are context independent
there's tremendous value in that they're
concretely reusable right so somebody
can make this and not know how you're
going to use it that has tremendous
value it's much stronger than
parameterization right because you can
flow it um it supports early termination
they support early termination
completion you can compose them just as
easily as you can compose the other ones
they're efficient and tasty thanks
yes